monsieur pierre ottino merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
concrètement quelle est la proposition
faite par la direction de la fnac
oui alors bonjour la wii la proposition
de la fnac c'est de revenir sur les
accords de temps de travail qui qui sont
actuellement en cours dans les
différentes sociétés fnac en échange de
ce complément de salaire qui n'est pas
pris en charge par les parts des fonds
publics
et ce jusqu'au jusqu'au 11 mai cette
proposition n'est pas encore acté c'est
on en est au stade de la discussion
on en est encore au stade de la
négociation mais on a bien compris que
la volonté de la direction c'était de
nous proposer un projet enfin c'est un
grand point d'interrogation de style
faites nous confiance c'est pour un an
et on fera on fera au mieux mais en
attendant vous allez faire des semaines
de 43 heures à la noël et vous allez
perdre vos jours de rtt comme celles qui
sont actuellement
alors selon vous le groupe at il les
capacités de verser la totalité des
salaires sans avoir recours à cette
modulation du temps de travail alors je
le groupe jusqu'à avant la crise avaient
des des liquidités assez solide la
hauteur de 500 millions d'euros là y'a
un prêt qui vient d'être 46 par l'état à
hauteur de 70 % auprès des banques ils
ont engendré encore 500 millions d'euros
de liquidités donc ça apporte des
liquidités à un milliard je pense qu'ils
ont les moyens
et j'ajoute que beaucoup de groupes de
la taille de la fnac
je vais les cités par exemple boulanger
mais il ya aussi leroy merlin près dans
le change tous les compléments de des
compléments de salaires donc la fnac
d'enfin fait assez office cette
exception dans ce domaine là ça veut
dire que actuellement ceux qui sont au
chômage partiel ne touche pas la
totalité de leur salaire seulement 70 %
du brut sur le mois d'avril sur le mois
de mars le demi mois a été pris en
charge mais sur le mois d'avril la
direction nous a annoncé qu'elle ne
complète aurait pas sauf sauf à signer
cet accord qui remet en cause les acquis
de jours de rtt de temps de deux ans de
travail deux jours de repos fils sûr
semaine et bien d'autres choses encore
puisque voilà l appétit de la direction
pour des truands ses acquis sociaux et
senteurs alors certains parlent de
chantage
quelle est votre position tout à fait
tout à fait là le maintien de la
rémunération est compliqué quand même
que les 70 % brut sont issus des fonds
publics sont issus des impôts donc elles
des salariés de la fnac paye payent
leurs impôts comme tout le monde donc
m o châtelet se compléter le salaire
c'est la responsabilité de l'employeur
mais de les mettre cette décision dans
la balance pour signer un accord qui
saura qui va modifier considérablement
la vie des salariés de la fac et pas
dans le bon sens
c'est du chantage mark pieth rossinot
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct je
rappelle que vous êtes syndicaliste cgt
relais à la fnac merci